you know people's attitude towards money
towards prosperity you told a great
story about going out to dinner once and
about and I'm gonna let you retell it
but all this came from the idea of like
people hating money and hating rich
people but also wanting to have money
and wanting to be rich and the problem
with that the inherent contradiction
with you know saying that I you know I
hate capitalism and it's all bad and I
hate and anyone that's made any money
sucks and then but at the same time
they're going I want more money and then
they don't know why they're not making
it yeah I think people equate the elite
which I don't like to call them the
elite the parasite class Rises people
who have made it you know there's a big
difference but I like old money and new
money people have made it have just
figured out that money is energy they
might not think of it that way but it is
an energy and you can tune into the
energy and then it'll just fall out of
the sky for you'll know exactly how to
link up with it so I was I'm white so I
you know do have some advantages but I
was raised poor my mom was an addict I
grew up in a trailer my first little bit
was her I there were ants in my cereal I
had to pour milk in and let them float
to the top like and now you pay 25
dollars for ants in your cereal and
poverty mentality like my dad was okay
like middle class construction worker or
whatever but they were still like so
much poverty mentality pumped into me as
a kid so I got married when I was a
teenager and was just didn't understand
money was terrified of money so it never
came easy to me and interesting now what
so terrified of why are you terrified of
money that's an interesting thing to
unpack so the conspiracy theorist in me
believes that there are maybe reptilians
that did this on purpose but most people
are programmed to believe that life is
about survival and that
they're just trying to survive and
they're kind of taught that everything
is scarier and more difficult it's like
if you if you raise an entire part of
the population to believe that they're
gonna fall through the floor at any
second they're gonna approach life
completely different than people who
know that the floor is solid kind of
what being raised poor around that every
single thing is a [ __ ] struggle and
there are things that just don't make
sense by math period
I know people who when I was waiting
tables they wait tables at a diner and
they're like well when I get more money
and I'm like how you gonna get more
money and they're like I you know I'm
like go wait tables somewhere where
there's more money you know I mean but
they just have nobody ever taught them
and I think it's strange the [ __ ]
they teach in school why don't we
teaching anybody how money works that
seems right strategic nobody understands
how taxes were that blows my mind you
understand what tax like how the tax law
works but so there is this just it's
such an abstract concept and all they're
taught is that it's hard and you're
never gonna get it and you have to work
really hard which is weird to me because
it feels like I don't know you just
their worker bees they're just
programmed to be worker bees all the
virtues are just worker bee virtues like
staying at things for a long time like
waiting out relationships for a long
time so you just have this class of
people who don't it's just scary they
don't understand it they know it's just
hard and so it was like that for me and
in like 2008 I understood that I was
creating my reality and I was like okay
I think in order to be rich I have to
figure out what rich people do this is
the the the premise of 12-step recovery
is find someone who has what you want
and do what they did that's exactly
right yeah it's exactly right
I've read books from self-made rich
people which I don't you know I skim
books and that's why I've been found me
because I'm just such an example of
peace and tranquility and love and
happiness did you want been anger yeah
hey you wanted rage it's like you think
I gotta find somebody that has what I
want then what do you want I stroke by
40 we got one